building muscle requires more than just
hitting the weights according to
scientific research these three powerful
foods contain vital nutrients in
addition to proteins that are essential
in the muscle building process number
one chicken breast it is a lean source
of high quality protein which is packed
with essential amino acids that Aid in
muscle repair and growth additionally
chicken breast contains vital
micronutrients such as niacin which
supports energy metabolism selenium a
powerful antioxidant and good quality
Iron in vitamin B12 which are all
essential for muscle growth and stamina
number two eggs are a rich source of
complete proteins that your body easily
absorbs eggs are loaded with muscle
repairing amino acids including leucine
and isolucine they are also in excellent
source of vitamin B12 supporting red
blood cell production and vitamin D
which AIDS in calcium absorption for
strong bones number three cottage cheese
consider it as a Hidden Gem for muscle
Builders which is loaded with slow
digesting protein known as casein which
promotes sustained muscle protein
synthesis throughout the day it's also a
vital source of calcium for bone health
and phosphorus for energy metabolism